When i was asking about about when he went
down to get the job and what he said.
After he given you that it would have got
the job first reckoned you would have
local threatened him so i mean
what. Oh well then. No i cause
a problem straight or had it when me and
i hadn't been down there anyway. But
apparently he had been threatened quite
a bit by these first because jobs are
so hard to get and if anyone did get
a job or if he knocked them back. I even
a pretty tough old fellow. Yeah you know
you're here we're very curtly you know and
yes just stand at the gate they are trying
to get in and as you went by i suppose i
had abused him for not going
to a job but he couldn't give
a job. To everyone but i was lucky
when i walked out. I happen to know
a fellow outside how do you go.
Don i said i wouldn't have
a clue. I said well it's and he said at
least you've got an interview i said that's
about all i got anyway
that same afternoon i get
a telegram to start the next morning. So i
did so but i didn't tell anyone you know
i didn't tell this from them when they got
the job. At the time because jobs were
really hard to get really james beer
was the engineer for substructure for
a doorman long wasn't he. You know. Yes i
don't know his full title but i know he
was on the job all the time and very
he lived here up but lankov away
somewhere greenish i think greenwich. You
know he was scottish was. I could tell
you what he was but he's a very
tough looking character i tell you
a very well in oh there's risk. He had
responsibility and i see from the records.
He had responsibility for the quarry
doubt it. Maria as well as the all the
foundations including the pylons that was
his job on the bridge but i believe that
went before the the bridge joined that him
and the superintendent for steel work
it well very well they they did one
side each so that mirror did both
the substructure and. The superstructure
supervision on the one side and on the
south side and that it well did them on
the other side all both the substructure
and the superstructure so that they didn't
have to go back and forth although i
will they couldn't anyway couldn't because
the bridge for the road was on their to
cross over you know that because i had their
own boat. Oh yes well that'd be great
. That's what they did so that after years
then when they joined then they resumed
their various responsibilities which was
one year for substructure and and well for
steelwork yes yes but as i say you
weren't there till after the i know your
a well know i was there to laugh to rejoin
in fact after the road was just about
getting laid by then and do you remember
when the bridge was joined around. Well
yes yes i saw it i took photographs of
it which i got here of it. Joined i went
down and i'm answer point and
took my own photograph of it and
a little flag flying the top
of the bridge denoted soon as
a joint they put that flag
up and i got a photograph of
a taken from mcmahons point with my little
old brownie camera which i carried with
me on
a bridge into some level fantastic photographs
taken. Yes i see this photograph is
a very good. Do you did you know that
frank cash. Reverend frank cash was
a photographer. He was
a very good photographer. It was his hobby
and he was given the right to go and
over at any part of that bridge and take
photographs and he climbed over that
bridge time and time again you're
seeing with this camera in
a bag over his shoulder and everyone respect
him. It was well known carried to down
there great fellow frank ash
and. In fact his young son john
cash came and played football with
my club for a little while when he's
a youngster and he went and joined the
air force and unfortunate was killed
overseas in that war. Yes. Did you know
anything else about cash at all. Frank you
know no nothing more about him. I only
got to know him through senior mine i'm
asked how he was i said i think that's frank
cassidy reverend frank cash from down
here and walks free. No signature sound
there. Did you remember his voice did he
have
a peculiar voice well i only heard him speak
you know. Ordinarily and heard him at
the service that they usually related about
the service. Just before that. Yeah.
Some people have said he had
a squeaky voice. Well i would write. Well
i knew avoid well you don't know when
they're in the churches. I suppose and they
speak you just take that much notice to
know that he could have had
you got to realize he's
a remarkable man in here but here he was
metallurgist alleges an engineer in
a western australian
goldfields before he became
a clergyman. He was but he got silicosis
and that and he was out of that business
and that's how he became a
clue to how we went became
a clergyman after the whole i did not know
that he was an engineer is all i did not
all that's wrong is to me
see he's his photographs
a superb collection of us right from the
western australian girl feels right over
here through the building of the bridge and
so many other things you have no idea.
Well and you know he's an amateur photographer.
You know he was thousands are glass
negatives. John breckinridge
was his helper. When he was
a lad and he had them all the way that's
all there. Yeah. I don't know whether
they've been donated yet but i
believe they will be if they. No.
No little bit about the bridge. I mean as
i talk about the last stone being laid on
the bridge right now in fact i've got
a photograph of that which i didn't take
i was up on top. I had to look as i was
working but on the last stone block of
ground that they went in the bridge which is
on the north western side
of the bridge. They had
a north north. No no. And i'm north
western side or bridge with this i n and
e there and i was on top of the pile
at the time we will working together
and i asked what was going on and
apparently as the stone was laid down we
understood that each of those
at roos. Redfield live.
Let's field you and all of those chappies
off to get know all their names lawrence
and. I and assess right and all of those
they cut two shillings in two or had them
cut in two and half of that two shilling
piece was put under that last stone that
when it on the bridge and they kept the
other half hours i meant oh maybe to hang
on a watch chain which what such
a woman who stays. But when i spoke
to dr bradfield son year or so ago at
a ceremony a bit of
a get together we old timers he did not
know that so i told my bit of history about
his own father or that titian in peace on
that last. So if you're to go and lift
a block of ground up. Now you know you
know probably fine if you have to shell in
pieces. I don't think anybody's going to
go there you are right. And so i only wish
i could do the same all the bits that i
got the souvenirs right along so i mean i
got
a big bit of granite as just chipped
off down the bottom of the foundation
of the pylon great big bit which when people
sometimes come from overseas. I might
ship them off of it and say there's
a general bit of sydney harbour bridge the
other thing on. Got here today is which
i use extensively is
a wire brush that was used to brush down
all the cement after the rendering and all
the get together when the cleaning went
down on the bridge with all the acid and
water mixture and all that and
we chipped it all i've got
a brush. When we won't do anything else.
And we're done later and we're put on this
brush to help. Rush down the
the pylon. And the granite and
i've still got the one of the
original brushes which i use quite
a lot myself here today when i'm doing
a bit of painting of the original bridge.
Tell me what was your actual work what
did you do when you were working as
a rigger well the job was we done the and
the other wrecked in the bridge at all.
Gantries
a little bits of scaffolds and go and after
job was done and you use cables you'd
have to put those cables down them roll
them up all the odd jobs about the place to
the odd jobs. Had you ever done done that
sort of work before with it. Ropes and
such like. No no i didn't even belong to
the boy scouts even. Even know whether ty
or not but you learnt
a bit there. You know how to do two round
turns and two 1/2 inches which. You know
which is quite good and i'm not so sure i
would have liked to have been on any of
your scaffolding i know. And i know i was
the other boys i know and you do you two
who always had to have two round turns
first to stop any step in and the two half
each just was the actual end of it and
then you know if you had a little bit of
a cable left over. You had when
you call women women and that was
a bundle of string type stuff and you
had to tie that to stop that from
moving at all so that would be absolutely
the. It had to be 100 percent. You
know. Not that was that was good enough.
It was not good enough and it was
inspected you know. So you had to make
sure you done everything. Well did jim
campbell show you in the first place. Oh
yes i met jimmy jarrett what to do but
course he had his off side us and
one thing and he was the general
man about the house sort of. Did you
come across to tom evans he was
a regular on the no i don't remember the
names years ago. You know you name time
and you know bill. Tom dick and harry as i
say but you never got to know many but i
fear the younger ones and i vented at the
time we used to go after work and go to
old water houses pub which is
a well-known name in the betting and
raising game the day old. Charlie
waterhouse that had the pub opposite. Well
i could tell some not some funny stories
but you know i'd be held up for defamation
i suppose of us to tell you those but as
you'd go in to his old pub an old
board floor not even linoleum have
a beer or two and in his backyard you have
chocks of the chooks would come into the
bar and there'd be besson on the
floor and the two boys they had
a pet goat or two or sheep
sheep if i can now i think was
a goat and i'd take them underneath where
the bradfield park is now to put on my
grass over there and this is
a true about old friend. Charlie what
houses pub. And i go down there and i time
for drinks made
a couple of young scots blokes and we are
all same age. We got on well together. Go
down and have
a drink with them and time and so he's
upstairs in bed. You know there i said what
room. Look up and up and room so as i get
up there and hear me. My mate line out
drunk to the world on a mattress
but there i go home. I have
a bearing go home on my own but you know
and i run remember one little incident.
Where we're liftin up by block and
tackle one of the big cables to put on
a truck. And as i swung away from the rope
which the guide rope that hit one of our
blokes and knocked him out. So they rushed
across toward charlie water houses pub
to get brandy for him he wasn't really
badly hurt by any means but is knocked out
a bit and shook shaken
a bit. So when they got over there. How
they come back ration with this glass
bottle of i think we're going to glass
or i forget now which but i was standing
there and this fellow waved aside i know
i'm all right so the fella looked at the
first around i love how the other then saw
all. Safety glass back to water houses
bob. He said well that's not going to go
to waste. The brand himself. You know you
could make
a story and see the funny things that happen.
Those days. I could go on reminiscent
of our time to just sit down and if i had
ever written down all the things that
i've seen on there and other
things and i i could write
a book you know. And it was felix for the
one that was killed was there when you
were there and one rescued all but i was
there i forget his name one survived you
know he was lucky he survived and
kelly i think is no more wreck. Yeah
one survived but likely but because
we never had the safety we do
those what to do today. You know the
safety things are all going to be where we
were there wasn't even any lahar the hell
helmet days those days there are no hard
helmets. Tell me you said in the beginning
that you were worried when you first
went up there
a bit later. Or do you started volunteering
for dangerous. Yes yes. What do you
mean by that. What did you volunteer for
that was dangerous. Well the job which go
when out on those temporary girders
a report up to put out the scaffold
that was hang down and do all the
pile and clean as wasn't for the pylon
cleaners and they took pointed i don't think
quarter took point in those days but the
finishing persons of the to do the face
work. Of the pylon you know and various
other little jobs you know which
for
a little bit risky which others didn't
want to do i sold out you know and which i
gladly done i thought
a better experience of course you were gay
more silly those days i don't know which
were both. Ready for when i was
a different story. Oh yes
a different story as one fella said to me
will do what we do. John john i said was
that one for the boss and one for yourself.
So when i was helping i remember first
job living down a bit of a scuffle in
down underneath the roadway we had to put
a temporary scaffold up there for the
cleaning purposes not from the top of the
pylon but just underneath
a roadway and i was let in down the rope
there and i said i grabbed hold of some i
forget now which was some part of the
structure and i made sure i had my left hand
round and round part of the structure on
the other one and down at the left and i
thought gradually you work into this. It's
like everything else you do you know you
take
a city for the first time and but as
you get more. You know you take you
don't you don't need risks that that's
like everything it take. No risk at the
beginning but in the end you when you
know you can do these things you do them
automatically but just still do it with
care and safety. You got any more. Stories
you can tell about the actual
working. What bridgework yes. Of
not really not really the only centred
around my. You know. Oh i was threatened
once myself and old scots tom. I suppose
i thought i thought i have been
a bit funny i suppose you know you know how
are you when you're young and you hear
people with the different voice
scots voice or an english voice or
a foreign voice. You're
sort of just ended in
a friendly sort of way but
he objected to. You're he
objected. Oh yes he thought i was hammersley
i wasn't really i sort of just you
know to be friends with everyone you
know you take everyone off and he was
a big great big giant of a fellow
with a beard. I remember he had
a beard and he said i won't have any all
that he said are you go with the so why do
. You know so i can mimic him and well him
i suppose i mean making everyone which
do these things out of fun more or less
and but he thought i was having a bit of
a shot. I wasn't really you know i was
trying to be friendly. I suppose but he
objected sort of having
a shot at him. And can you remember any
of the other people who worked on the
bridge that you could tell stories about
the only one that i can tell stories you
know as i say they've got
a lot of fellas in experience all
that i work and one person who i got
a job. Some of his mates got
a job on there when i clean it down. We
had to climb up ladders from one scaffold
to the other when we are going home overnight
or knocking off. For lunch. Whatever
it was just saying i might have to
a tree scaffold up and they were connected
with forty foot ladders and you had to
climb down these letters onto the next one
and down to the next one like. But that
fellow from the time he went on the job
you don't like clean inside of things he
never looked round him once because his
friends told me if you looked around once
you deformed and there were and it scared
as though they had to one fell there in
front of me as i went down the ladder one
fella guiding him down another fella
holding him his back to assure him that
everything was safe and the story was that
this prolific his name. Jim or something.
Never looked round once when his climb
a climb up level out as he was scared all
the time scale all the time but i don't
know i mean that was just nature i
suppose. Yeah but yeah see i suppose.
Well those days when you know people think
nothing of it you know but others. Well
necessity necessity for getting up
a. Well there's one area
of that we haven't covered
very much at all. And that's your sporting
career. You keen on sport all your life
i've been i've never been married you will
always know i've been married someone
ask me why i never got
married i said i never had
a spare saturday afternoon because it's
too busy unsporting if it wasn't plain
rugby in winter. It was sailing
a summer or down surfing or with my surf
club or anything so actually i never had.
Never had
a spare set out but anyway that's my
story and so good. That you had to look
after your mother. Yes when she got on i
have seen much of your father started. You
started school or were forced to leave and
i thought no i don't know i left early
those days because those days i had no sport
it's girl much nothing at all. Nothing
really no organized when i look at it
today and see what's given to the young
fellas today. I know i thought well and
i wish we had it those i know we had
nothing. No really sports master we weren't
encouraged to do anything and maybe add
if i'd gone to high school which i didn't
because i couldn't afford to do those
things. Maybe they did at those schools
but i was in force. Enough to go to high
school i had to leave as i said
before i even turned fourteen to get
a quid. But. I first i had two years
playing soccer is planned soccer
a friend of mine's a friend
play soccer got me had
a couple of the soccer but i didn't go on
with it and i knew others i played rugby
i said well come up and i am
a rugby. So i joined up northern suburbs
rugby football club in 1927 and i'm still
with i'm in nineteen eighty eight. So it's
a long long time i played.
Oh played. I suppose it's
a record number of games i've played
a were well over 600 games are
rugby with my club. Six hundred
over 600 games we never recorded them but
of well over 600 i plagiarize fifty three
years of age and they reckon i was getting
a bit old which i jacked it to
i thought i could it or not
a few people here. I carry my togs for
a couple of years after that my
cousin going with a fourth grade as
a hooker and the course in the summer
time i sold on the famous old eighteen
footers when they were really eighteen
foot as they were timber boats. And with
eighteen foot eight foot beam eight foot
been about twenty inches of deck in space
to put your spares so that i left
approximately just sixteen sixteen foot of
space and sometimes we carried
a crew of ten eleven even twelve on when
we had the big sail on. And other times
you might only take about six or
seven. But you carried a crew in
a sail to what the weather was or going
to be or what your thoughts sometimes of
course if you get over to our garden island
i don't go and i'm sorry. Clark island
where the boat started from the skipper
thought he had to me on board any cause of
the. The wind lightened off
a bit. So he said rather you you and you
dive overboard but i was lucky i i was
lucky i was
a sheet hand and i because i had my job
to do one of few two or three of the boys
that have to do over how and we pick them
up on the way back after the race but
they were funny days and they were tough
old days those days and you had to work
hard. There was no fun about it at all.
You were never it's fun but hard. But you
can always remember the boats. Sometimes
you would not give away sometimes you know
you know race and you've got to give way
to the other boater on window view. Well i
ask you i wouldn't give away one day so
the other boat come alongside us they
jumped around boat
a couple of their crew started fighting
with our boat our bloke fought them back
and there was
a fight going on between the two crews delay
their skipper yelled out get back onto
the bloody boat he said we're sailing not
fighting and these i'm telling the truth
. These are things i went on those old days.
Remember one day we were going down to
towards bradley's head and everyone
on the shore where house and just
a follow the races those days and i
called out my old skipper which is
a great little scout that final me and bob.
Look we are going he said i know where
i'm going and he instead of keeping his
eye on on his forehead and it was looking
to see the shallows on the rocks is giving
us an idea. So it's giving him the sign
to go about to get away from the rocks of
east where in and he's replying to these
fellas on the shore. You know how many shot
at him. I know where i'm glad all going
he didn't he went up on the
rocks and we tipped like
a bent nuffin. Then the
fin which she had a put
a big they still finnan
about there's days. Not
a keel leak on the fin those days and we
had to get pushed off someone come and.
Good enough or we jumped out and pushed him
off the rocks but we couldn't continue
because our fin was bell. So we let drop
down the sail went home by the jib and it
took him hours an hour so not down
the centre box what they called
a box in the boat but you know i remember
that in the winter i know where i'm glad
it all going well it went up on the rocks
and then the fed. Oh little things like
that and that was a drop you wasn't it
a girl to have found just dropped australians
there shop to straight in and pull it
out again and well when you went oh no.
When you know when about not about when
you've got the wind behind you down when
you lose to lift it up and put two pins
through to take the weight from and use
lifted up in the box which is in the boat.
And lifted up and put two pins in to the
depths length of what you want of what
skip would say that's near enough
and you put two pins through it
a toehold and keep it up to
a certain height to see but course when
you know blow and there to court you went
a full length of the fin. Do you have
a tack block and tackle to drop it down
and looked it up though. No no you had to
hand to two of the crew would pick it up
two handles lift it up lifted up and while
there lift and up to other support the
pin you see was that steel was it. Oh
quarter in one of our friends when we had
a big sale on quarter inch steel. It took
two blokes to carry it down to the boat
and put it in. Oh my word and as luck would
have it. I had an old eighteen foot and
when i was
a kid in england i bought this this thing
it was called anyhow. And it was built in
100 to go and buy five brothers who sold
it themselves. And it was made it too. You
can credibly amount of money to cost them
a solid ticket mahogany it wasn't
that it had a. Ok keel. But it had
a block and tackle to get it down and up
that heavy was cast iron here. Oh well
just to our crew just to come down at an
angle like that and i can tackle that
with i think we had three fins one for
the small so one for the medium sail and
this great big one when we had the big sail
on and there and norma speak sales norm
just because they're different. I call them
toys these days. We go faster than you
know well. Well much faster because they
are made of. I think laminator would be
safer or something or other very
fine timbers and of course they have
a three man crew and they have the.
You know all this light sails of.
Very light sails very light spars house
bars those days were solid solid timbers
solid. And sort of mast
solid xt. You know when we
put out the old balloon and all that this
happened the other you know it don't
relent of the spinning spin they go up.
And i waitressed it. They had made of two
or three pieces and they had a feral and
put them together. Push it out and have
a bit of a rope
a snot as they called it round the mast
and hooked it in that and it took some
doing when you had to push out that spinning
there is no fun about it so it took
some work. Now all solid spars but of
course with the sales as those bean counter
sales they had to be but now with the
light things they got the elemental saw
whatever they have them. Everything's light
on and those days it was more or less
an art sailing then was something
and we have this me like of
a saturday afternoon which i so never
bob on the sunny sailing. There were
sometimes three and four ferryboat sister
by the thousands of people you know and
the old bookmakers just get on
board on the other go and have
a great little time on board and. The
ferryboat should be. When hilo had you know
the decks were awash with water. You know
fought the good. Ferryboat so they should
take all that they were on the top deck and
on the lower deck watching fall and the
races around the house the people
fought on those days and it was
a greater go in an internal you know it
take about so many legs down the harbor go
about and oh it was really exciting really
exciting but it was hard work but you
enjoyed it. You enjoyed it and if you got
to be more stories about different times
or in what way on the boats you know. Oh
well i suppose there are one funny day.
Yes i can also call this. It was that
it was a city from fly and i sydney
a much as sony club. It was
a lady's day and there was
a. Chappie they md captain spain
which spain's wharf rode round
here and neutral bay and he was
a great hole sailed in these sailing crowd
and it was ladies day in our old skipper
he was
a rough old harris whirl like mad and we're
going around. You're just headlight and
course i suppose
a bioscope i thought or where the eight
and put us and this little boats going
round and east ask you some great abuse
of language to our poor old captain spain
and all the sudden our crew got
a bob shut up. He said there's
a lady on board and he's and his tone
of voice changes said you know mr.
Spain. You shouldn't do that.
From the. It's sublime probably
go blind to the sublime as
a result of our life it always
voice changes you know mr.
Speed but we're sure that these
seas and god knows what the change
what was he was gibbous moon. Bob barber.
Oh well known. Well known one of sydney's
characters one of the sydneys
characters and what club at
a city flying squadron the same club down
here at any point to any cove city finds
for the same same name same name. You
didn't know any of the book is burnisher no
no. Well we're never on the ferries we
ought on our boat and i never knew any of
them never i believe they had
a great old game on board there and you
could lay bets there. I would like to
a met some and no no. Well as one of
them but i know that we give the 100th
birthday this weekend at the bellamy
believed. Well he wouldn't have any of my
money because if i was asylum not a
better. Not a follower of the matter of
a big it was only a punter himself
if he did it did it because he was
a punter is by the i think there are only
two bob bets those days expenses and two
bobs you would you know you'd be
pretty well to do if you could have
a five bob bet those days i tell you
. What about your rugby days you went
overseas later on. Oh well yes i did go. I
went with my club of course i'd given up
play and then but i've had five tours
overseas. I went to the
three times to the u.k.
I went to the year of the gland slam and
saw the card of test and where we had
a pushover try which surprised
everyone. And we went to the test in
and brown saw that. This just
not two years ago into a.